à salviac dans le lot il y a une piscine
un seul es un court de tennis un terrain
de football
c'est bien pour une commune qui avoisine
les 900 habitants c'est encore mieux
lorsqu'on apprend qu'une entreprise
vient de s'y implanter
et pas n'importe laquelle nous suivons
tout de suite à salviac hélène pronos et
jean-claude classant au pays des mille
et une nuits l'argent a une odeur celle
du pétrole
une odeur que l'on peut respirer
jusqu'au fond du lot dans un petit
village de 876 habitants ici dans cette
ancienne école marqué du sceau de jules
ferry
des centaines d'enfants ont usé leurs
fonds de culotte il les aurait
volontiers échangé contre ses habits
somptueux tout froufroutant de soi et de
dentelles car c'est ici que claude cas
s'est installé pour fabriquer des
vêtements destinés aux petits princes
des pays du golfe qui trempe dans le
petit caution très chargé plus de 20 g
puis sont contents on rajoute de tout ce
qui monte en fait surfer sur commande
d'après croquis mais s'ils veulent de
choses plus brodé plus travailler les
laves pour les lépreux saraben faire la
fête et on goût du luxe les robes de
claude cas varie entre 5000 et 7000
francs et ne seront sans doute mis
qu'une seule fois
qui peut s'en plaindre les pétro dollar
font vivre le commerce français claude
cas exploit 75% proche orient et a saisi
le créneau au bon moment maintenant il y
en a davantage parce que bon bah tout le
monde a voulu essayer aussi de prendre
une part de ce marché mais surtout
spécialisé on et 34 sûrement faire ce
genre d'article globalement il ya
d'autres fabricants qui font des choses
différentes
tout le temps d'un créneau de coûter la
classe des filles de l'autre la classe
des garçons tous se penche ce cru se
dessine ce calcul et se réalise dans ce
petit atelier
mais claudia et son mari n'en sont
joints à leurs débuts ils n'ont fait que
transférer leur entreprise de paris à
salviac le ciel de la capitale leur
paraissait trop gris celui de salviac
trop bleu ils ont choisi au grand
bonheur des lotois qui voit de plus en
plus rarement des créations
d'entreprises on exporte
quant à ça et si la guerre je crois que
ça change pas grand chose
c'est la qualité de vie qui est la
meilleure pour moi oui ça va mieux et
votre clientèle et déjà toutes établies
oui on a déjà tout un réseau de clients
qui sont visités par un agent commercial
et puis en fait le salon de la mode
enfantine deux fois par an ça suffit et
ici à salviac comment ça s'est passé
j'imagine comme un dieu vous accueillir
à bras ouverts
ah oui mais pas beaucoup de travail en
entreprise mais aussi petit que les
autres sont toujours contents
l'euphorie des années 70 est en train de
se calmer le marché arabe n'est peut
être plus aussi florissant qu'à cela ne
tienne claude cap toujours habillé les
petits français
elle propose une collection très bcbg
rien à voir avec les perles et
paillettes
le saviez-vous les quelques